تصريحات اخرى ايضا للرئيس جو بايدن مع
دخول حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا عامها الثاني
حيث قال الرئيس الامريكي ان اجرته لم ترصد
اقدام الصين على تزويد روسيا بالسلاح في
حرب على اوكرانيا واضاف ان الولايات
المتحده سترد اذا فعلت الصين ذلك
لا اتوقع مبادره صينيه كبرى لتزويد روسيا
بالسلاح
ان اقدم على ذلك هل هو تجاوز
سيكون مثل التجاوز الذي ارتكبه اخرون في
السابق وفرطنا عليهم عقوبات
اذا العواقب لا يستهان بها ساترك التوصيف
لك ولكننا سنرد
وفي المقابله نفسها التي تابعناها قبل
قليل ايضا انه لم يرى جديدا في المبادره
الصينيه لانها الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
واضاف ليس هناك ما يؤشر الى وجود مستفيد
من هذه الحرب سوى روسيا اذا اعتمدت الخطه
الصينيه واوضح اذ اعتمدت الخطه الصينيه
واوضح الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان فكره
ان الصين سوف تتفاوض على نتيجه حرب غير
عادله تماما بالنسبه لاوكرانيا هي فكره
غير عقلانيه